[Musica]
io
ciao a tutti qui in tornati sanità
source oggi a grandissima richiesta
nuova challenge trova di ingredienti
slime ma il personaggio di oggi sarà uno
dei più inquietanti in assoluto e ce lo
avete richiesto voi non mi fa paura
simo ma continuate a scrivermi che
volete vederlo e sapete chi è e sarà
allora qual è la storia di samara ve la
racconto molto velocemente anche se non
me la ricordo bene perché ho visto il
finto dopo fa comunque allora samara e
una bambina che esce dal pozzo una
bambina indemoniata con tutti i capelli
neri davanti ed esce dal pozzo e se non
mi dicono male e sotto al posto perché
era stata buttata del pozzo e quindi la
sua vendetta e uscire dal pozzo comunque
dovrò cercare ingredienti sta e non
essere presa cinque volte tanto amara
come congressi solo che era molto più in
cui dovessero presidenza mare penso devo
ancora vederla finora non ho sentito
nessun rumore ma so che lei è super
silenzioso comunque se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace il prossimo
episodio sarà trova gli ingredienti
strana e con il pagliaccio di it
pennywise che un altro personaggio che
può per paura forse il più inquietante
di tutti comunque ora
mettiamo ad esplorare un po io sono
dentro la casa e te la riconoscete
ve la ricordate questo è il mio posto
sicuro perché in genere non riescono
entrare qua dentro
meglio che chiudo le finestre
ecco fatto qua sono sempre al sicuro
quindi mi rifugio quel dentro ma ora è
arrivato il momento di andare anche
perché non so dove sia berlino
sicuramente merlino guidato ad andare ad
esplorare sapete di marino va sempre in
giro a cercarle questi personaggi anche
se non dovrebbe comunque ma sembra tutto
molto tranquillo
usciamo e vediamo cosa c'è
vabbé di tipo barbè figli marino che ci
file i pinocchietti fallita sono insieme
qualcosa che stai guardando
fino qua mi stavano mente tetti dio che
buio manzù molto inquietante
ciao marino no non ha termini di berlino
vabbè io da morti iniziare a cercare gli
ingredienti mi raccomando anche lui
state attenti vedete se c'è qualcosa
qualche sì qui veramente inquietanti qua
non potrebbe comperare merlino è
sembrato di sentire il rumore marino sei
tu cos'era
se questo amore
o no si è così e così è successo sono
riusciti materna era talmente bureau che
non vedevo bene ma ho visto solo capelli
lunghi neri davanti era inquietanti non
voglio più andare laggiù
ora non so se è ancora lì forse ancora
io si spostò po troppo paura di andare
la gioia ho già perso una vita io sono
quattro adesso li a molto agitato deve
aver spaventato anche lui
[Musica]
almeno passa un po più di luce
ok vediamo bene niente paura che punti
poi all'improvviso berlino sei tu sia il
tipo incastrato fantastico e xstrata che
mezza
giusto in tempo perché non riesca ad
aprire le porte quindi specie da fuori
ma non posso farci niente se apro adesso
aperto sicuramente si riesce a vedere la
foto per per fortuna perché molte di
avere proprio una bella faccia
quest'anno
sì
[Musica]
via riesco a far entrare il berlino fino
qua piedi fino sbrigati
pini bravo bravissimo bravissimo fino
ora costi ma sicuro
non ti preoccupare m dino
non merlino carlofortino canada via
ok questa volta ci siamo andati molto
vicini non stavo per essere presa una
seconda volta che si ammalino perché è
più anzi forse meglio non si è scolato
comunque almeno sono riuscito a prendere
una paletta subito qua della mia casetta
al secondo ma ci mancano ancora la
ciotola la colla il bicarbonato nella
soluzione per 24 cose e ho solo quattro
giorni deve collaborare ok devi fare
silenzio e devi avvisarmi se la vedi da
qualche parte così almeno riesco a
salvarmi
[Musica]
cosa qua ha detto mi sembra
completamente vuoto che c'è berlino
perché guardi lei c'è qualcosa
marino saputo trendy che hanno qualcosa
vedete dicendo che lì non c'è qualcosa
di christine berlino sono riuscito a
trovare la soluzione per lenti con la
prima rivista la era troppo buio per
averli lavora benissimo
[Musica]
il collega stefano carlino aiutami a
trovare la colla con il tuo fiuto aiuta
[Musica]
ok perché prima sull area è spuntata
dalla dieta uccisa forse proposte
all'improvviso perché il 40
dell'armatore aperte
andiamo potrà dare forse c'è qualcosa
qua quindi spunti samara c'è solo un
ferro da stiro marino aiutami con un tuo
fiuto dove la colla se qua mannaggia qua
non c'è niente che c'è berlino così
fiutato marino sta cercando qualcosa
[Musica]
ecco stagione della prima poi
sicuramente ve ne siete accorti vero e
là sopra come fatto a prenderla lo
cerchi estro qui neanche un punto
dipinti arrivo
[Musica]
prenderò city o salire qua sopra
ok è bravo a tagliacozzo ora speriamo
bene
si fa forte come lui mi guarda
però non porta
c'è mancato pochissimo
non ci credo che sono riuscita a
prendere una colla dalla su senza essere
preso da sfamare incredibile ho ancora
quattro possibilità mi mancano il
bicarbonato la soluzione per lenti e mi
dimenticavo della ciotola quella è
importantissimo come valletto e tutto
quanto
ecco qua c'è mancato davvero un po
la scheda chiesto
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa sotto il divano vedete
qualcosa che brilla con rispetto
sì
ora mi appresto posso comunque riuscita
a prendere la ciotola c'è quasi tutto
manca solo il bicarbonato fatto in cui
tantissimo sono spaventata uno stacco
vabbè ora devo mettermi a cercare il
bicarbonato o no cosa ci fa qua dentro
ma dpa non puoi prendere miqua che vuoi
miami a berlino
[Musica]
venatorio sia andato via
berlino ma dove ieri si può sapere chi
sono preoccupate un sacco che stai
cercando
stai cercando samore ovvero meglio che
non la cerchi pericoloso ok siamo
d'acqua
penso che si stiano panatta stato
veramente inquietante mi sembra che ci
siete
[Musica]
il carbonato il prima possibile
controlliamo bene ogni singolo non c'è
niente siamo qua
[Musica]
certo
che c'è marino mi spaventa quando corre
così sembra che abbiamo sentito qualcosa
[Musica]
storia nascosta non sa così paura
mettiamo dentro questo armadio sia
qualcosa
l'altra volta ciò che aveva nascosto qua
moto ecco dei cavi non mi servo ma che
non aiuta mi devi risparmiano il tuo
fiuto a trovare il bicarbonato di sodio
tie in ascolto che si stia avvicinando
[Musica]
si sta avvicinando stato i passi
poi una scossa quando penso che mi creda
ero quasi tutti prestiti fatto cioè
ancora non ce l'ho fatta perché devo
prima fare lo slime altrimenti st mora
non scompare ho trovato tutti gli
ingredienti
ora andiamo con molta calma
[Musica]
ecco con la ciotola o il bicarbonato
ho preso tutto con su sentimenti e
pathos che dopo per subito la colla
anche per scoprirlo sbrighiamoci riga di
cosa si può sentito più posti sempre
sentiti lungo ma non capisco da dove
provengono
[Musica]
ascoltiamo sei mesi punto ragazzi non
capisco dove stamane quando guardate
ragazzi quasi pronto però non posso far
sparire ma samara perché non c'è forse
vuol dire che devo andare a cercarla
maledizione dovete portare a cercarla di
scolo sahin è pronto ma samara non c'è
come faccio
e scomparso ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta
per un pelo non ci credo ce l'abbiamo
fatto ragazza esito anche uno slam
superbello super rosa comunque l'estate
un mi piace se volete una seconda parte
con samara e se volete trova gli
ingredienti slime con il pagliaccio di
it pennywise e ora vi lascio qui a 4
castellina su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e buona visione